la ville de cergy qui a fêté aujourd'hui
l'achèvement d'un nouveau quartier celui
de cergy le haut pour marquer
l'événement une manifestation
spectaculaire ce matin une chaîne
humaine de plusieurs milliers d'enfants
l'occasion aussi de fêter le vingtième
anniversaire de cette ville nouvelle
frédérique hovasse dominique boucher et
eric mangani un mini larzac ccl à cergy
dans les années 70 des champs de
betteraves à 30 km de paris
le domaine défendu des paysans une ville
nouvelle créée par décret en 69
baptisé dans les cartons certes oise
c'était le symbole de la société de
consommation
l'espoir est l'axé pour beaucoup de
familles au confort moderne en rêves
déçus un projet avorté sur 460 mille
habitants prévu ils ne sont aujourd'hui
que 160 milles et ce sont leurs enfants
qui avaient les clés de la ville ce
matin pour l'ouverture du dernier
quartier une chaîne humaine de 6 km
traversant d'un bout à l'autre la ville
nouvelle
un symbole ici 50% des habitants ont
moins de 25 ans ça sert à quoi cette
foule est là
ainsi pour ouvrir aux attentes de cergy
le haut et alors c'est sûr toi tu as
fait ce matin le matin cieux
je suis allé jusqu ici pour faire la
gueule la chaîne humaine cergy-le-haut
ses 500 logements déjà construits de
gare sncf et revers à des commerces et
un bâtiment de bureaux sa boucle les
constructions parce que ça évite déjà
d'avoir l'entrée cela la campagne
et pour ceux qui sont à côté depuis
quelques années cette news
c'est une fin puisque en fait maintenant
on n'a levé que 5 est à la porte
ce nouveau quartier nouvelle époque
espérons que la fête dure longtemps